قبل أسبوع ، عندما ألقى
الرئيس خطاب الافتتاح في أكاديمية ويست
بوينت العسكرية في النهاية ، كان
يسير في منحدر ،
دعني أريها أذكر مشاهدينا بما
حدث ، لقد كان حذرًا للغاية بينما كان
يسير على المنحدر يمكنك رؤيته
هناك و  ثم في النهاية قبل
أن يلتقطها قليلاً ، هل كان جيدًا ،
هذا ما أعنيه أن الناس كانوا
يتساءلون عما إذا كان بخير في وقت سابق
أثناء حديثه وأراد أن يشرب
بعض الماء و  دعنا نظهر لمشاهدينا
ما حدث ثم التقط
كوبًا وسنحصل على هذا الفيديو
لمشاهدينا وهو يشرب الماء هنا وهو
يسير على المنحدر ولكن دعنا نظهر
لمشاهدينا شرب الماء هذا
ما كنت على بعد عشرة أقدام  باختصار ، قلت إنني عامة
، أنا آسف لأنني قمت بذلك ، وركضت الباقي
بشكل صحيح ، وأبدو وسيمًا جدًا لأن هذا كان
الشيء الجيد الوحيد الذي لا أريد أن أركض
في كل شيء لأن الأحمق
هناك سيكون سيئًا بالتأكيد لذلك أنا  أخذ
هؤلاء  خطوات صغيرة ركضت في
العشر الأواخر وبالطريقة التي ألقوا بها على الشريط
نظرة في كل مرة تقريبًا ينتهي
الأمر قبل أن أركض ،
تعرفون أن سانجاي حساس للغاية ،
هناك أي إشارة إلى أنه ليس بصحة
جيدة الآن لم نفعل ذلك.  للحصول على مقطع فيديو
له وهو يرفع كأسه ثم
يعرضنا هناك ، يمكنك رؤيته
هناك مباشرة في الجزء الأيمن من
الشاشة عندما كان يشرب ذلك
الماء ، إنها مشكلة حساسة للغاية
بالنسبة له ، نعم ، أعني أنها لطيفة  من
اللافت للنظر أن نسمع كيف يصفه
الآن ، ولكن بعد عدة أيام ، لا يزال
يتحدث عن الطريقة التي يقول بها
إنه وسيم وأنه يركض
في المنحدر ، إنه أمر غريب حقًا ، لا
أعني أي شك في ذلك ولكنني أعلم أنني
أعتقد  نحن من منظور طبي
لا يمكنك التكهن حقًا بأنك تعلم أنك
لا تعرف ماذا تفعل بهذا ، أعني
أنني أقوم بهذا العمل لمدة 20 عامًا
جيدًا إذا كنا نعرف أقل عن
صحة هذا الرئيس مما أعتقد أن أي شخص آخر
لقد غطيت أعني  الأطباء الأوائل
الذين كانوا يعتنون به
كان لديهم في الأساس الرسائل التي
كتبوها أملاها عليهم البيت الأبيض ،
وكان لدينا طبيب آخر يقول
إن الرئيس يمكن أن يعيش حتى 200
عام ، لديه هذه الزيارة الطارئة يوم
السبت إلى والتر ريد في هذه الزيارة
المفاجئة المفاجئة  زيارة إلى Walter Reed يوم
سبت من شهر نوفمبر ، لا نعرف حقًا
ما
أعنيه ، لذلك لا نعرف وأعتقد
أن هذا هو سبب
فضول الناس عندما يرون شيئًا
غير معتاد هناك ولهذا السبب
سألوا  هذه الأسئلة الطبية ولكن
لكي نكون واضحين ، إنها تكهنات لا
نعرفها ولا ينبغي لأحد أن يشخصها ،
أعتقد أنه عبر التلفزيون لا ينبغي لأحد أن
يفعل ذلك ، فأنا لا أعرف لماذا هذه الأشياء
لماذا تعرف أنك ترى هذه السلوكيات
بعد خطاب ويست بوينت ولكني  أنت
تعلم أنني أتمنى أنا وآمل أن تقوم
الفرق الطبية من حوله في حالة وجود
مشكلة برعايته
وإخباره أنه يجب فحصه أو
مسحه ضوئيًا أو  يكره يحتاج إلى القيام به